c'est un petit truc pour toi c'est quoi
ces faits une surprise non ouais ton
morceau préféré de cet album on aura un
petit truc c'est quoi bah tu vas voir
c'est parti
d
je parle
m
de tous les côtés on va
hattestad tu peux compter sur moi on
rendez vous et le
vous
à
côté
ça m'avait stade tu peux compter sur moi
monsanto est faux
ah ça y est c'est le black et un clip
avec tous tes potes non ses nerfs à
sortir la semaine prochaine on ira vont
monter fatale merci lycées ou de mercy
mcsherry à la valérie damidot et nora
valérie gilles verdez bertrand le
collectif métissé bien sûr mon elie
semoun
ça fait plaisir de voir florent peyre
saint amour aussi merci les ch tis a
fait fait très plaisir et gilles verdez
ce qui est formidable pour les cards qui
ont fait juste ce qu'il faut et à
jean-luc un voyage en lui-même dans sa
période à un poste il a été dur jean-luc
idole j'y crois pas bien de voir le clip
merci en tout cas à monteux face à leurs
canaux merci mon chéri ce qui est que
des gens qui aiment vraiment allez on y
va et liabeuf ya pas qu ami c'est dedans
si bien qu'à milan kaka me donnant
rassurer mouallem faire une histoire
sinon
oh